as thousands of illegals Trek towards
our Southern border many critics are
pointing to Europe as a warning of
potential reprecussions of unchecked
illegal immigration in Italy more than
155,000 migrants reportedly landed this
year up some 50% from the year before
according to Italian news outlets that's
most of that is by C and in Germany a
brand new report indicates at least
7,000 women have been sex assaulted by
illegal migrants since 2015 when the
country became an epicenter for Europe's
Refugee crisis here to react is
documentary filmmaker Amy Horowitz Amy
thanks for being here you you have
covered this illegal migrant issue in
Europe extensively how bad is it and
what is it what kind of preview could it
be for America where we're taking in
even
more yeah no it's it's bad and it's
beginning getting worse and it's across
Europe right Italy this is kind of a
somewhat newer phenomenon I think
Germany France Sweden has have been
dealing these issues for a very very
long time and it has had uh massive
social ramifications I think I know that
a lot of Europeans want to ignore that
and they've ignored it for years and by
the way that ignoring of it has led to a
tumult in those countries um if you look
at Germany for example uh the the
illegal immigrants that Germany make up
about 2.5% of the population that
excludes the ukrainians right that's
carving the ukrainians out now 25% is a
large number in of itself but if you
look at if what the ratio in terms of
the amount of violent crime committed by
the illegal immigrants they make up
about 10% of violent crime so the huge
out outperforming of their population
Set uh no it's been it's been terrible
and in terms of the ramification and the
lessons we can learn the US look we're
seeing a similar massive migration uh
from our Southern border and I think we
it's a preview of things to come not
only that I think the left Democrats in
particular should take note more than
anybody else because what you've seen is
you've seen this illegal immigration in
Europe driving a move to the right
you've seen now in Italy in Norway with
ger builders in the Netherlands you've
seen a pol a massive political shift
happening to the right primarily driven
by the immigration crisis if I'm a
Democrat and and we know that the
immigration uh crisis is a one of the
top issues along with inflation in the
economy here in the US I would take note
and I would be very very worried uh
great point I mean you know you take the
stat of the 7,000 sexual assaults by
illegals in Germany um there's two
multiple parts to that but a a lot of it
is that these folks are coming from
countries with very different uh social
norms you might might say and and
they're not assimilating to those
countries but then also the press in in
these European countries I followed this
very closely they they will often not
acknowledge that the perpetrator in an
assault isn't illegal they'll work very
hard to to not talk about that so they
don't even want to acknowledge that this
happens no the the the immediate
malpractice on this issue is epic and
has been for many many years I learned a
lesson firsthand when I had an explosive
video in Sweden that made international
news across the country I was
interviewed by CNN by BBC by by by
Reuters everybody in the country I did
an interview with and of course all they
would do is try to push back they were
put they were they were kind of like uh
uh trying to get them form themselves
into logistical pretzels in order to to
push back of the notion and the reality
that there is a social dislocation and
large amount of crimes that come from
the people particularly when it coming
from the nations of the mreb right the
Arab Nations primarily because I mean
let's be honest that women don't have a
very high status in their culture and
they bring that culture frankly over to
Europe again not to say that all or even
most these people are committing crime
it's not the case but it is a it is
there's no question that they do it at a
much higher proportion than the locals
in those countries yeah you they don't
you don't protect your your borders and
you don't protect your culture than you
get other cultures with very different
views and then your own citizens suffer
as a result Amy Horowitz thanks for your
time appreciate it I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis